sur ce plateau jean baptiste eyraud
porte parole de la fédération droit au
logement bonjour merci d'être avec nous
christophe robert lé délégué général de
la fondation abbé pierre évoque un
risque de banalisation de ce genre de
mobilier urbain anti sdf
est-ce que vous avez des chiffres
concrets par rapport à cela
à l'écouter il n'y a pas eu de
recensement en fait hein mais c'est les
pratiques qui se développe dans beaucoup
de bâtiments qui sont situés dans les
centres villes
un somme de d'entreprise groupe
financier et même de communes mettre en
place des transports en commun aussi met
en place du mobilier entier ce bief pour
empêcher des sans abri de s'installer
moi j'ai j'ai connu cette époque où les
sans abri dormait sur les bancs dans le
métro maintenant c'est terminé on peut
plus dormir sur les bancs dans le métro
d'abord les ont enlevés et puis là où
ils ont mis quelques sièges bon il ya
des des poignets qui empêche de pouvoir
s'y allonger
justement quelles sont les villes les
plus
il est qui qui pratiquent le plus ce
genre de méthode on a entendu paris lyon
lille pourquoi c'est parce qu'il ya plus
de concentration de deux sdf dans tout
ça c'est des grandes villes à des
grandes villes qui sont
qui accueille le plus de sans abri parce
que quand on est à la rue on essaie de
se mettre dans des endroits qui sont un
peu plus chaud si vous voulez bon on a
un peu plus de chance de survie et donc
c'est sûr que dans un village en pleine
campagne
il se passera rien c'est que dans une
ville on a trouvé de quoi se nourrir on
tout le monde quoi se laver des deux
d'accueil
malheureusement on trouve pas d'endroit
pour se loger pour dormir
c'est ça la difficulté qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans les métropoles
françaises et une crise du logement
sévère qui fait qu'on a de plus en plus
de sans abri dans le pays pourtant fin
janvier on le ministre le ministère du
logement a parlé de 150000 sans abri ou
mal logés qui ont retrouvé un logement
grâce au plan logement le logement
d'abord prévue jusqu'en 2022 bonne
nouvelle et 150000 sans abri après la
question c'est oui c'est parce qu'il a
estimé
il a pris les personnes qui sont sans
logis qui sont hébergés à droite à
gauche etc et qui ont obtenu un logement
social ou qui ont obtenu un logement
intermédiaire mais malheureusement ce
dispositif là suffira pas c'est à dire
qu'il faut vraiment produire du logement
social de manière beaucoup plus
importantes plutôt que que deux
cesser de financer comme le fait le
gouvernement actuellement la prod la
production de la construction nouvelle
de logements sociaux et donc c'est bien
pour les cent cinquante mille personnes
mais il faudra garder un petit peu plus
près six chiffres je crois qu'ils sont
un peu biaisé en réalité vous parler de
chiffres biaisés
il ya un autre chiffre que j'ai envie de
vous donner ce sont les quatre millions
de personnes mal logées en france en
il y en aura combien selon vous en 2020
quelle sera la tendance par écouter
malheureusement la tendance à augmenter
dans la tendance augmente c'est à dire
que il ya de plus en plus d'expulsions
locatives
les loyers continuent à augmenter les
prix de l'immobilier flambent la cherté
du logement produits inexorablement de
la crise du logement s'est c'est comme
ça et donc il faudrait prendre des
mesures très vigoureuse pour
rendre on va dire le logement accessible
à l'ensemble de la population y compris
les ménages très bas revenus
d'une part et d'autre part mobilisé les
logements vacants qui existe et enfin
produire du logement social
aujourd'hui on conduit des politiques
notamment à l'heure des élections
municipales il faut quand même rappeler
que les communes et les communautés de
communes ont tendance à mener des
politiques d'urbanisme très agressive
qui font monter les prix de l'immobilier
tout le monde tous les pouvoirs publics
en règle générale encourage de la
flambée des prix et la hausse des loyers
très peu de communes ont pris des
mesures par an pour bloquer airbnb
locations touristiques qui qui assèche
le parc locatif privé donc qui font
monter les prix dans le parc locatif
privé sur l'ensemble du parc immobilier
on a aussi n'oublions pas trois millions
plus de trois millions de logements
vacants et les communautés de communes
sur les agglomérations les des
rassemblements de deux municipalités
pourraient demander la compétence en
matière de réquisition
pourquoi ne le font pas aucune aucune
communauté de communes en france
pourtant il y en a des centaines
non non demander la compétence
réquisition pour pouvoir loger les sans
abri rien que les sans abri qui sont sur
le territoire
eh bien non c'est inacceptable on
préfère ériger des dispositifs pour les
empêcher de dormir dans la rue pour les
faire disparaître de la visibilité pour
qu'ils aillent se cacher dans les
recoins
plutôt que de les loger
trois millions de logements vides en
france un million de plus qu'il ya dix
ans c'est intolérable ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on a des centaines de sans
abri qui meurt dans nos rues qui meurent
de froid de maladie de fatigue de
suicides d'agression et tout ce qu'on
fait c'est de les chasser
pour nous c'est il faut arrêter c'est un
véritable ces criminels
c'est un crime alors que le droit à
l'hébergement existe c'est une
obligation qui pèsent aujourd'hui sur
l'état excusez moi je m'emporte parce
que ça me met en colère c'est terrible
c'est ce qui se passe dans notre pays on
a des lois qui sont violées on a ce
droit à l'hébergement de toute personne
sans abri qui appellent le 115 doit être
hébergé jusqu'à son relogement
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que nous allons
manifester le 28 mars pour demander la
mise en oeuvre des droits des sans abri
des mal-logés des locataires
la baisse des loyers et l'arrêt des
expulsions sans relogement dans toute
l'europe parce que ce problème là se
pose dans toute l'europe
nous manifesterons le samedi 26 mars à
parler ça sera à 15h et donc beaucoup de
villes en france il va y avoir des
mobilisations
il faut que les habitants et les noms
habitants ceux qui n'ont les habitants
des trottoirs aussi ses habitants des
foyers les habitants et locataires et
ceux qui supportent plus cette situation
descendre dans la rue c'est le mot de la
fin merci jean baptiste eyraud de mamers
il répondu à une question rappelle que
vous êtes le porte parole de la
fédération droit au logement